When,
when you,
when you sync that these jobs are going
to be automated and then universal basic
income is going to supplement their in,
it's going to give them some money,
$1,000 a month. But where do
they go from there? I mean,
how do people exist on $12,000 a year?
Like what do they do?
Like how do they adapt to this new world?
Right?
So the first thing you have to do is you
have to look at what lies ahead if we
do nothing, right? Uh, so the,
the way it's going to play out is that
self driving trucks are slowly going to
start hating on highways.
Amazon's testing them out right now.
And the first stage is going to be that
there is a human driver just sitting
there as a fail safe and the
truck's going to drive itself. Uh,
now my friends in Silicon Valley
are working on tele operators, um,
which is, so the trucks have right
now, like a 98% accuracy level,
which is not very high because you can't
have 2% semi trucks like running into
things like the roads.
So,
so the way they're trying to get the
last percent or so is there equipping
trucks with tele operating software,
which means that a trucker,
a tele operator in Nevada or Arizona,
we'll beam into the truck and just be
able to see out the front like a video
game, uh, like uh, let you
know it's like drone operating,
but instead of the truck and you beam in
and then you just steer the truck until
the computer. It's like I got it
from here and then you beam out.
That's what they're working on to try and
catch that last bit of uncertainty. Uh,
so the innovations are
happening and again, Joe,
we're talking about $168 billion a year.
Like everything becomes possible when
you're looking at that much money.
So in the absence of
anyone doing anything,
the robot trucks will start
reducing shifts of various truckers.
I would say six to 10 years from now.
And so then there'll be a
bunch of reactions. Now,
trucking firms already
have massive shortages.
They can't find enough people.
That's one reason why they're trying to
automate this job as fast as they are
because they're literally like,
you know,
they're short like a couple of
hundred thousand truckers right now.
And people don't want to go into
this field for a variety of reasons.
The main thing being it's
like extraordinarily brutal
on new, physically very,
very bad for your family life too, because
you're away all the time. Yeah. Uh,
something like 88% of truckers have an
early marker for chronic disease, like,
oh, like substance
abuse, diabetes, obesity,
high blood pressure or
something along those lines.
And now people think that the jobs going
to disappear in the next five to 10
years. You can't get people
in. So if you play out,
what happens when the robot
trucks start reducing shifts,
then there'll be people trying
to flee the field of trucking.
And then if it becomes really dramatic
where the robot start driving,
let's say between western Pennsylvania
and Nevada and then human beings get in
in those states and then take it the rest
of the way because the robots won't be
reliable enough to drive an urban areas.
There'll be reliable enough to drive on
an interstate or they just have to make
a few decisions,
uh,
then there'll be a massive depletion
of truck driving opportunities.
And then in my mind,
a lot of suicides,
a lot of self destruction.
And I don't say that lightly.
I say that based upon the fact that
that's what happened in the manufacturing
workers where if you unpack what
happened to the manufacturing workers of
Michigan, Ohio, Indiana,
suicide rates spiked to a point where
now our life expectancy as a country has
declined for the last three years because
of suicides and drug overdoses. Uh,
it's the first time that's happened since
the great flu pandemic of 1918 like we
are actually coming apart
as a country by the numbers.
So what happened to the manufacturer
and grooves will then happen to the
truckers,
but at a it even more dramatic scale.
So you'll see truckers just going home
and drinking themselves to death or, uh,
doing drugs and overdosing
or killing themselves. Uh,
and then eventually there'll be an
outbreak of violence because some truckers
will say, instead of killing myself, how
about I go bust up a robot truck? Uh,
and there are already truckers that
are doing things like blocking Tesla
recharging stations
and electronic vehicle,
a battery stations because they
don't like electronic trucks. Sword.
Those are pickup trucks though.
Those are assholes.
I mean this is not like
people doing it because they,
they think that these Tesla recharge
stations are taking jobs away.
They're just being dickheads. Exactly.
Joe. So if you're going to be a dickhead,
even though it really has
nothing to do with you,
imagine when you actually think your
livelihood is being threatened. Right.
Good point. Then you can see
it getting revved up, you know,
to like a much higher level.
So,
so I'm running for president in large
part because I think we need to get in
front of this set of problems.
We have to say, look,
if we're going to save
$168 billion a year,
maybe some of that should go to the
truckers and give them a soft landing.
Maybe we should have this universal
basic income where everyone feels like
they're getting 1000 bucks a month,
which is not a work replacement.
It's not going to make their lives easy.
They still need to work,
but at least it takes the edge off. It
takes like the existential threat off. Um,
and also their kids getting
it. So they feel like, okay,
my kid actually has some kind of path to
the future and it's not like if I lose
this trucking job, not only am I going
to, you know, struggle and suffer,
but my kid will too. So, uh,
my plan as president is to install
a trucker. Transitions are and say,
look, it is your job to try and manage
this transition for the three and a half
million truckers.
And Joe,
we haven't even talked about the 5
million Americans who work at truck stops,
motels,
diners,
retail establishment is all the places
where the truckers stop every day just to
get out,
eat a meal and live a life mean.
If you imagine those communities,
when the trucks don't stop,
there's going to be a drying
up of economic vitality.
On a level that's unprecedented.
Many of these communities.
This is something that I,
I'm just becoming aware of
over the last year or two.
Um, how, when when you were out on
the campaign trail and you know,
you're talking to media and you're
discussing this with people,
how many people have no
idea that this is coming?
Well, what I say to
people, Joe, is I say, Hey,
have you noticed stores closing on your
main street? And then they say yes.
Then I asked them why is that?
And then they reflect for
a minute and then they say
Amazon. And I was like, yeah,
that's right. It was us getting
$20 billion of commerce every year.
And it's now tipping your malls and main
street stories into oblivion and like
is that going to get better or worse?
Cause so some people say
it's like hop the robots,
the robots are years away
and then you're like, no,
it's not robots actually like walking
around your neighborhood. I mean,
of course that's unlikely.
But Amazon soaking up the business
that used to go to your mall.
If you go to their fulfillment center,
it's robots as far as the eye
can see if you go to their uh,
their warehouse, you know, it's also
robots as far as far as the eye can see.
So when you ask how aware are
people that this is happening,
it's one of those truths that as soon as
you pointed out, they're like, oh yeah,
like I,
I knew that was what was up is just for
whatever reason I'm like the only person
just laying out the facts and being
like, guys, it's not your imagination.
Like we actually are getting rid of
the most common jobs in the U s economy
filled by high school graduates and then
replacing them with a handful of jobs
for higher skilled people
in different places.
And then we're pretending that the first
population is somehow going to access
the new opportunities when the odds of
them getting up and moving to Seattle or
whatnot and becoming a web designer or
like logistics manager or a big data
scientist or something
like essentially near zero.
And so this is what gave rise to a
lot of the anger that got Donald Trump
elected because they looked around
their communities and we're like, hey,
I used to work in this
manufacturing plant.
This manufacturing plant no
longer exists for whatever reason.
Like I'm being told that it's somehow
like my fault that I wasn't adaptable
enough. Like I didn't, you know,
I didn't somehow become a
coders or something ridiculous.
Then I have to say,
Joe,
and this is like something that
I've picked up from Dennis and part.
So I'm with this trucker in Iowa
and he says to me, he says like,
I don't think that Democrats
care about people like me. Uh,
and he says that to me while I'm
in his truck and I'm just like,
I can understand why he feels that way.
But that's incredibly destructive because
there is a point at which Democratic
Party used to be very, very heavily
aligned with working class Americans.
And there's now it's some kind of a
pathology that if the person who is
suffering is a white man of a certain
background than the suffering somehow is
like somehow like diminished.
Like it doesn't count as much
if they're a trucker. Uh,
and that's something that
I find really destructive.
It's like we have to start acknowledging
the source of the problems.
One thing I'm saying to people is like,
look,
it's not immigrants that
are taking these jobs away.
Like just facts that is not immigrants.
It is the fact that technology is pushing
our economy in a direction that makes
it harder and harder for many Americans
to get by based upon this current,
I trade my time for money model now
truckers seemed to be the big one,
right? Yeah. A cashiers are another
one. Yeah. Um, what are the other job?
The jobs that are going to be
killed by automation. So the,
the next obvious one is call
center workers. Of course,
where there are two and a half million
call center worker is still in the United
States. Generally high school
graduates, they make about $14 an hour.
Now when you and I call a company were
like pounding keys trying to get a human
because the AI is so annoying, you
know, it's like, Hey, but you know,
just like gimme gimme a person. Uh,
but over the next number of months,
AI is going to become industry
indistinguishable from a person. Yeah.
Like the new Google answering service
that comes with the pixel phones.
It's amazing.
Yes.
And so that two and a half million call
center population is going to shrink a
ton because after you get AI software,
that's better than one of them. You know,
it can be most all of them, you
know, that's not like 5,000 jobs.
That's potentially 500,000 jobs.
I was at a conference of CEOs and I asked
how many of them are looking at having
AI replace back office workers
like various clerical functions.
Every single hand went up.
There's going to be a lot of
clerical work, having systems talk to
each other that's going to disappear.
And one CIO type of like a major bank
said that his estimate was that's about
30% of the bank's workers
fall into that category.
So you're looking at call center workers,
you're looking at back office worker
as you're looking at insurance brokers.
Insurance is a very highly automateable
industry cause it's a lot of information
getting passed back and forth.
Cashiers, as you said, truck drivers,
delivery drivers, Uber drivers. Uh,
did it goes even as far
as medical procedures.
There was a recent automated a medical
procedure where they did surgery on a
grape. Yes. Yeah. You see
that? Yeah, I saw that.
And China's already had just a complete
automated dental implantation because
China actually has a real shortage of
surgeons and so their incentives to try
and automate this are very, very high.
Now the interesting thing here, Joe,
is that let's say I made a robot
surgeon tomorrow that was awesome,
could do better work than a lot of people.
Um,
right now the economic incentives still
are not necessarily for everyone to use
my robot surgeon because the regulations
aren't there yet in the u s and so
healthcare is a really interesting one.
Another one that's very clearly going
to get taken up by Ai is radiology and
looking at tumors on a film because it
turns out that AI can see shades of gray
that a human eye cannot.
And it can reference millions of films
where the most experienced doctor can
probably reference thousands.
And so radiology, I'll tell you,
medical students are running from
radiology as fast as they can because they
know that's going to get taken up by Ai.
Man,
this is such a bleak forecast.
It's very strange when we stop and think
about all the different things that
human beings find value in as far as
their occupation. Like, Hey, I'm a this,
I'm a,
that this is what I do.
And that the idea that these things
are all gonna go away, it's very,
it's kind of disturbing. Oh, and when
I was digging into the research show,
it's been happening and it's tearing us
apart. I mean, I referenced the fact that,
so here are some things that
are all taught at halt all time.
Our multi decade highs right now in
the United States of America, suicide,
drug overdoses, uh,
anxiety and depression,
mental problems, uh, financial insecurity,
people being unable to pay their bills,
all of these things are at
record highs in one thing I,
I know you've talked about in the
past that I think you'd really find
fascinating.
So there has been,
there have been studies as to what happens
to your mind when you can't pay your
bills and when you can't pay your bills,
you're like stressing out. It's like,
if I pay this,
I can't pay that.
And there was like always the time
money trade off. It's like, Oh,
if I spend extra time commuting,
maybe I can save a couple bucks. Uh,
and so what it does is it actually
constrains your bandwidth to a point that
your functional Iq goes down by 13
points or one standard deviation.
So just if you say to someone,
Hey, here's a bill you can't pay.
And then you give them an Iq test,
their score actually goes
down by 13 points a lot.
That's like a really huge effect. And
so what we're doing right now, Joe,
is we're actually making our population
less rational, less reasonable,
more impulsive, more subject
to bad ideas, Nastier,
more subject to things like racism and
misogyny too because it turns out what
happens with most of us is
you need executive functioning
to resist like racist
and massage,
misogynistic impulses.
And so if I make you cash strapped and
make it so you can't pay your bills,
you're actually more likely to be like,
yeah, like, yeah, like blame them.
So what your, what we're talking about,
again, it's not the speculative future,
it's that we've been doing this for
years and it's actually pushing our
population into a mindset
of scarcity of nastiness.
And that's why universal basic income is
so crucial because it gets the boot off
of people's throats and it replaces the
mindset of scarcity with a mindset of
abundance and rationality
and optimism and capacity.
Like I'm an entrepreneur. You're an
entrepreneur. I'll tell you, very,
very few entrepreneurs start businesses.
At a scarcity where they're like, oh,
I can't pay my bills. I guess I'm not
like starting a new company like that,
that like most of them,
but $1,000 a month isn't even enough
money for most people to pay for the rent.
Well, the great thing is, again, this
thousand dollars is yours no matter what.
So right now, let's say you're,
you're doing a normal job. Um,
so if you make $1 million a year, he's
still got $1,000 a month. Yes. Yes you do.
I mean, it's opt in so you
could opt in and take it,
which most Americans would because
it's still 1000 bucks a month. Yeah.
People get greedy. Yeah. For sure. Yeah.
Thousand Dollars to get my
nails done. Yes. Or give it
away. If they were, you know,
they felt like it. Yeah.
Yeah. But the, this,
so those are the things that
are at like all time highs.
It's like all these
negative social indicators.
Here are things that are at all
time, lows, getting married,
starting a business, having
a kid, moving for a new job.
All of those things are at historic lows
in the United States of America having
children. Really? Yeah.
We're at record low birth rates right
now and it's largely because people feel
too strapped to have kids.
I mean that's literally where we are.
When you say record low by
like what percentage you can
look up right now, Jamie,
I don't know if you want to look this up,
but stories have come out over this last
year or saying that Americans are now
at the lowest rate of childbirth.
That has been the case in decades or ever.
Yeah,
that's a conversation that I have with
people whenever they say that they're
worried about population,
that the population is growing so
fast and overpopulate here it goes.
1.8 births per woman,
2016 what does that mean?
So it's dropping from 1970 at a high.
Well, it seems fairly, fairly
similar from 1980 to today.
That's still,
I mean that's,
it's actually like if it
goes from 1.8 till like uh,
if it goes from even something like 1.9
to 1.8 is like a pretty significant drop
us birth dip to 30 year low fertility
rates sink further below replacement
level.
And so you think it's about the thought
is that this is because of education and
this is because of people are waiting
longer to have children and that this is a
byproduct of industrialization and modern
world and that the more educated and
affluent people get,
the less likely they are to have
children then it's not the site.
As far as what everything I've read about
it is that that it's not a symptom of
people doing poorly.
It's a symptom of people doing well.
You know there,
there are definitely cases where Richard
countries just have fewer kids and
that's cool because they concentrate on
their careers, right? It's not the idea.
But the darker part of this,
Joe,
is that right now if you're a non college
educated person in the United States,
the odds of you are ever getting married
less than 50% now for the first time
ever. And then people are
having fewer kids. To play
devil's advocate though, the,
the marriage thing might be
people looking at it and go, God,
my parents got divorced, my brother got
divorced, everybody else got divorced.
What the fuck am I doing? There are a
lot of good reasons for it. It's just,
you know, as a, as a happily
married man and myself, me
as well, I always tell them,
don't do it. I tell people don't do it.
It's just, it's too risky. Yeah. So,
so you can look at,
to me,
certainly to me getting married and
having kids like an act of like prosperity
or optimism, there are reasons
why it's going down otherwise.
But if you look at things
like starting a new business,
I mean that being at multi decade lows,
there's like no positive spin on that,
right? People moving between
states is now at multi decade lows.
Uh, people moving for a
new job, multi decade lows.
They think this is the product of
automation or it's a product of a bunch of
different factors like Internet purchasing
and marketing and think people buying
most of their goods. And it's a range
of factors. But one of the big problems,
and keep in mind,
I spent seven years helping entrepreneurs
grow businesses in 18 cities around
the country, between 2011,
2017 that was actually my job.
My job was to be the job creator guy.
And so when you go out to these places,
you see that the dynamism is getting
sucked up by certain markets to a level
that's unprecedented in
our history like that,
that the disparities between Cleveland
and San Francisco or Saint Louis and La
are much, much higher than they've
been at any other historical period,
both by the numbers. And like after you
actually go to the places you're like,
wow, like this is not a
flourishing the way that you hope.
Do you feel like an economic
Paul revere in a certain sense,
like the robots are coming, the robots are
coming? I do. Uh, it's weird, man. Well,
what the comparison I make is that if
the United States economy is like an
elephant, you know, the parable
of the people, like, you know,
blind people touching the elephant.
So I'm, I'm an entrepreneur.
I sold a company to a public company
that was a national education company,
is based in New York. What
does the parable, blind people
touching an elephant. Uh,
so what happens is a,
they're,
they're like seven blind men and
they get asked like, what is the,
what does an elephant look like?
And then one of them is touching the
trunk and is like an elephant looks like a
snake and another one's touching his leg
and it's like an elephant looks like a
tree trunk.
Uh,
so that's the way most people experience
the economy is that they're like
touching a part of the
economy and they're like,
this is what it looks like or feels like.
So I've had this really strange set
of experiences where I sold, uh,
a national education
company to a public company.
I lived by coastally between New York and
San Francisco for the last five years.
I've operated in 18 cities
around the country. I was, uh,
I was an appointee in the
Obama administration in DC.
So I've actually seen the elephant, if
you know what I mean. Like I holo. Yeah.
Like I'm, I'm like hanging out with, uh,
the tech wizards and Silicon
Valley and I'm like, Hey, you know,
we can automate these jobs
away. And they're like, oh
yeah, we're going to the job.
Like it's, you know, so it's not a mystery
and they're not bad people. It's like,
Hey,
it's my job to like made stuff.
And if you gave me a choice between
making things work better and creating
abundant opportunities for the
other people, I would choose that.
But I do not have that choice. I have
a job to do, you know, this is my job.
And what I tell people is
like, whose responsibility
is it to go tell the people,
look,
it's technology.
It's transformed the economy
in fundamental ways and
we need to make it so that
everyone benefits.
And it's not just that this like hyper
concentrated set of winners and then this
like huge army of,
of relative losers and
it's the government's job.
But at this point we've given up
on our government as anything,
like it can't really do anything.
And so now it's no one's job.
And so somehow Joe, it has become my
job and it blows my mind too. Sometimes.